people talk about Trump I go love them
or hate him this would not be going on I
don't care who the hell you are who you
vote for if you can't at least admit
it's horrible right now and it's not
getting any better than that's exactly
and that's why my frustration with
journalists that just want to talk about
her should Walker's past history of
whateverness yeah I want to say come
here get my hand I'm going to walk you
through downtown where I was just in
Atlanta come see if people there really
care about Herschel Walker's background
or do you think they care about the fact
that I just watched a lady have a
cigarette snatched out of her face and
have her bag take I mean I got involved
in that and that was returned but the
point is you know that is the reality of
on the road and things are collapsing so
fast here and it is terrifying to watch
but what I see is a result of that
having just spent three weeks on the
road in California is red has never been
as red like the red is dug in it's not
going anywhere and it's there to fight
and that's why I think the midterms are
going to be a massive result for for the
red